[Music]
fifty Shades freed is the third and
final thank all things holy Fifty Shades
movie and I never have to watch any of
these again which is something I'm
extremely happy about then I'm gonna go
celebrate actually as soon as I'm done
filming this and editing it and posting
and I'm gonna celebrate I'm not happy
Anastasia Steele has now married
Christian Grey
the billionaire owner of this giant
company who also really likes to whip
her and tie her up and she started to
like it herself and as they go from
vacation to vacation a stalker from the
past resurfaces and threatens her that's
the plot no joke that's all that happens
in this movie it's an over 100 minute
movie where all they do is go around on
vacations before the last fifteen to
twenty minutes shows up and some guy
kidnapped somebody and now it's like a
big race against time oh and there's a
chase scene with a wonderful song
playing I know for a fact that me
sitting here saying the third Fifty
Shades movie is terrible is not gonna
surprise a single soul on this earth but
it is this is the perfect trash trilogy
lips you know we had the Lord of the
Rings trilogy which is one of the best
ever each entry amazing now we have the
exact polar opposite in the Fifty Shades
trilogy but my friends and I still sat
there throughout this entire film all
the way to the end credits where we saw
the bit that comes up where we learn
about their future that was great but
honestly this entire film really is just
them on vacation having sex that's it
like the last ten minutes some
happens that's it when you really
picture a trilogy and you understand
what a trilogy is it's about characters
changing over time it's about their
journeys it's about where they start and
where they end and how we appreciate
that journey with this film trilogy
we have Anastasia Steele someone who
starts out very awkward and
introverted meeting some rich asshole
who has some serious issues and then
they enter into one of the most toxic
relationships ever to be portrayed in
cinema history and in this film what
exactly is the culmination of these
events they continue to have sex he's
still a strange extremely needy person
with very serious issues and she's a
little less introverted now and a little
more on top of things there's some very
serious mother issues with Christians
past and they try to at the very last
second interweave those into the plot so
we can have some sort of finality for
that but for the most part these movies
are just softcore porn for people who
don't actually want to go and watch real
porn they just want to watch Fifty
Shades of Grey or fifty shades darker
freed in a theater filled with other
people and watch it surrounded by other
people who are awkwardly sitting there
watching this happen on a giant screen
what in the living hell is enticing
about to experience but all that's
obvious ok that's what all of these
movies are like they're all like that
what does this film especially do that's
shockingly awful well any time there's
an action scene it's amazing
like it's the best movie you've ever
seen because if you watch it from like
the perspective of oh my god they're
actually doing like a big car chase in
the Fifty Shades movie it gets kind of
entertaining from that perspective every
single moment seems to have to have a
pop song of some kind including the car
chase there's a montage where she
remembers their past lives just like in
one of the last Twilight movies it blew
my mind it was like watching one of
those like anime music video
compilations are like heavy romantic
part of some anime romance
it was incredible it's like this is
happening I just wanted to actually open
the script and read that part of the
script like interior Anastasia's room
she approaches doorway looks at
Christian cut to flashback random
footage from the previous two cut back
to interior and his
I just want to see that part of the
screen oh there are so many
cringe-worthy moments with Christian
being a needy little asshole just
walking up to her like for instance
after they get married and she is in her
office she doesn't want to change her
email they have a whole scene dedicated
to the fact that her email is Anastasia
Steele at whatever and she doesn't want
to change it to gray cut to a few
minutes later gray storms in the office
I tried to send you an email it bounced
[Music]
he's like really traumatized by the fact
that she did not change her email to
Anastasia grey from a comedy perspective
this movie is great it's about it though
the film isn't even sexy just like the
other two the sex scenes are just
strange and awkward and the relationship
like I said is so toxic that you can't
really get any enjoyment out of those
scenes either it's just a giant
disappointing mess and it's one of those
things that's embarrassing it's
embarrassing that this is a trilogy it's
embarrassing that they make money Fifty
Shades freed of course gets an F well
this is the perfect F trilogy I don't
think that's ever happened before
usually when a franchise starts with a
truly awful atrocious entry they just
stop making them but nope not with this
they have a built-in audience of people
who for some reason like this stuff
definitely not one of those people yeah
don't waste your time with this you
probably weren't going to anyway no
surprise that I'm telling you that guys
have a good day I am so happy now I'm
freed I'm fifty Shades freed from having
to see any of these movies again and I
can't wait to never ever talk about them
ever again in my life guys thank you so
much as always for watching if you like
this you can click right here and get
steppen eyes
[Music]